maybe as news chief Washington
correspondent Face the Nation anchor
John Dickerson is in Washington John
good morning we want to talk about the
president at the United Nations but
first the Russian probe by Bob Muller
what does it mean what are the
implications over what we see happening
in Paul manna Ford's case well we knew
when when Muller had that pre-dawn raid
of home mana fort's house that it was
serious and that the he had convinced a
judge to have that kind of a warrant
issued but now we know because of the
wiretap we have more specificity that
that investigator Muller really seems to
have something on mana Ford now the
question is does it have anything to do
with the campaign it could be completely
outside of that but that means that he
has information to pressure mana for DES
and can use that information as a can
opener to go and get whatever it is that
he wants and make mana Ford talk about
anything it might have happens there in
the campaign is it normal in a
circumstance like this that you tell
someone you're likely to be indicted
well that's what The Times is reporting
if that's in fact the case you could
imagine saying that because it gives the
the person that you're investigating a
sense of the stakes and might loosen
their tongue a little bit particularly
in this case if if they are in trouble
for something on one front that you
might be able to use to squeeze them to
get information on another front the
reports are that Paul Manafort was
wiretap both before and after the
election when he was known to speak on
multiple occasions with now president
Trump which raises the question is
President Trump how was he recorded it
does raise that question and and we
don't really know the the the question
would be if the conversations he was
being tapped on were within the whatever
the FISA Court said was was okay to look
after and we just don't know the nature
of that but it's certainly if he was on
phone conversations with him and there
was a broad wiretap then it's certainly
possible and the detail to John that
they picked his lock and then accosted
him while he was in his bed says that
they were really trying to get him
that's a whole nother part of the story
but let you go ahead well it just gives
you a sense that they they again because
they had wiretaps they had some sense
that there was something that he was
hiding from them that they attacked fast
let's talk about their presence
speaking today to the United Nations
what are you looking for that's being
described as one of the biggest speeches
of his presidency what are you looking
for well there's there will be talk of
values and some some more vague talk but
I'm looking for specifically are the
direct messages he's gonna send in North
Korea and China when we talked to
Secretary of State Tillerson on Face the
Nation this weekend he sent his very
first message was to North Korea we're
not trying to change the regime we're
not trying to invade part of the
negotiation here is to try to keep that
message clear to North Korea there's no
better way than to specifically do that
in this speech from the president second
is on China the u.s. is trying to argue
to China if you want to be a player on
the world stage you have to work here
with North Korea this is a chance for
the president to send that message
publicly again
John Dickerson thanks so much for
joining us this morning we'll bring you
the president's speech to the General
Assembly in a CBS News special report is
expected to begin around 10:00 a.m.
Eastern 9:00 central